welcome to this video playing get nice
89 2 141 yeah maybe I can do something
in the Slav with queen bee three I think
I have a pretty good score with this
opening losing rally and and winning so
yeah once idea to maybe here I can start
with the smooth is Queenie to and then
later expand in the center
yeah no I'm really playing for next if
here is not preventing it with like this
okay i can go 1291 I guess provoking the
caption c3 hard to do anything else
really
nine xt4 so what has gotten some made
some progress in the center ok i'm i
mean i'm getting i'm taking this space
may be a 4 even know is this to lose can
it could be am Bishop you six then f4
could could be to lose mm-hmm didn't do
that ok I take the center
hmm ok we increase the pressure only
five the night is better on air free any
way that only one
oh why is giving up the center
completely even not even 94 is an idea
because of the weakness only six but i
guess i just take with the pawn a fry
FEI come on f5 and Bishop f4 that's all
with the tempo again 'if I've take
stakes there's a check on on c5 so f5
hangs at the end
that's unfortunate really what is this
ad do I have six at the end happy six at
the end now it's dangerous but probably
not winning amazing
and I don't really have a Grimm yeah I
can take our just but it's not it's not
really convincing okay 'if I've the
whole the whole setup is geared towards
pushing in the center so not doing it
now would be really weird
it's not the window I mean you can play
Queen d5 and it's not clear what I'm
doing next maybe Queen Queen somewhere
and then the night the night to attack
the Queen on d5 but hmm yeah if I've is
not even threatening something I mean my
queen is also attacked on e2 so maybe he
has some entirely different move
available that I'm not in considering
okay okay maybe come on when a temper
Brooks not bad on b1
maybe I can get the rook to e3 hem queen
a 5-4 okay three but then it's got 95
it's very unfortunate
and I have the chicken t3 it's still not
helping maybe this one no I can take on
a two
I don't I need to get rid of this pinion
as looks very shaky some sort of
combination of taking on a three and
only 5 is probably good for black it was
mostly hoping that Jack is some gets me
some counter play against this King but
it's a very very wake hope now I can
take with the queen is what I entirely
overlooked check
yeah even that is possible I mean he has
not seen rookie 3 here but it's it's not
time money's not a way it's not a
problem funny enough check
always some is playing it very passively
that's that'sthat's good ha ha ha no no
no no no what is better now I'm not
taking a row here
check
checked miss played it again I cannot
believe it I cannot believe it check
check check check check check no I went
on time ever know losing time this this
plight forfeits on time yeah that's the
drone now now Karen it's really
everything at the same time yeah I play
like an idiot and and the weirdest stuff
happens I mean here what is just
basically winning in the end game and I
cannot manage to I don't manage to win
it I need to get into e6 of course of
course maybe he just has the right
counterplay to draw maybe he has but I
know ruchi 7s tanning of course I hate
it I hate it how can you be so out of
shape yeah well this is this is totally
easier and here King age six and three
resins I just promote the prom ah come
on I really hate it yeah i need to
punish this kind of play I mean
absolutely sorry no decent player ever
we'll play look be eight this is double
? in the rook endgame you cannot play
this and I don't punish it this is what
I hate ya such a bad stuff like group b
8 and then i play it so badly that I
don't win ah yeah PR king age 6 was very
easy yeah I know and now it's probably a
draw check now rooks you seven wins
again
check but okay I have to add 13 seconds
this is this is clear and here we have
seven of course means but okay he was in
being on time mode anyway Jack check
that gentle jackets after some
adventures winning again for white but
ok the main thing is after Luke piayed i
need to punish this already need to and
it was weird that the whole situation
i'd really didn't see a move I mean it
was quite strange that there is now he's
backing up all the moves screwing up my
analysis ok I stopped this video here
thanks for watching